♪ ♪
>> WITH HEARTH SIGNATURES TODAY
WE WILL DECLARE THE INTENTION OF
OUR THREE COUNTRIES TO REPLACE
NAFTA.
WITH THE USMCA, A TRULY
GROUNDBREAKING ACHIEVEMENT.
MODERN-DAY AGREEMENT.
THE NEW AGREEMENT TO LIFTS THE
RISK OF SERIOUS ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY THAT LINGERS
THROUGHOUT A TRADE RENEGOTIATION
PROCESS.
UNCERTAINTY THAT WOULD HAVE ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE AND MORE DAMAGING
HAD WE NOT REACHED A NEW NAFTA.
>> THIS DAY IS THE CULMINATION
OF A LONG PROCESS BASED ON
DIALOGUE AND NEGOTIATIONS THAT
ALLOW US TO OVERCOME DIFFERENCES
AND TO CONCILIATE OUR VISIONS.
SPILLING MEXICAN PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THE
PRIME MINISTER OF CANADA SIGNING
THE TRADE AGREEMENT, THE
PRESIDENT CALLING IT THE BIGGEST
MOST IMPORTANT, LARGEST GREAT
DEAL IN THE U.S. AND WORLD
HISTORY, WE ARE HERE AT THE
REAGAN LIBRARY, WHEN HE TRAVELED
AROUND THE WORLD IT WAS THE G8,
NOW IT IS THE G20, AND THE
PRESIDENT NOT EVERYONE BACK IN
WASHINGTON IS FULLY BEHIND THE
NEW TRADE DEAL.
>> WHAT IS NOT AND IT IS ENOUGH
ENFORCEMENT REASSURANCE
REGARDING WORKERS, PROVISIONS
THAT RELATE TO WORKERS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THERE ALSO HAS NOT BEEN A LAW
PASSED IN MEXICO IN TERMS OF
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS IN
MEXICO, SO WHEN ALL OF THAT
HAPPENS PEOPLE MAKE A JUDGMENT
ABOUT WHETHER THEY ARE
SUPPORTING IT.
>> Bret: WE WILL START THERE
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S TRIP TO
THE G20, WE WILL BRING IN THE
PANEL FROM WASHINGTON, MORGAN
ORTAGUS, LESLIE MARSHALL, AND
DAVID BRODY, CHIEF ANALYST FOR
THE CHRISTIAN BROADCASTING
NETWORK, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
TRADE DEAL AND THE G20 ABROAD.
>> I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
RIGHT THAT IT IS A VERY HISTORIC
TRADE AGREEMENT, TRADE IS ONE OF
THE MOST ARCANE THINGS THAT ANY
ADMINISTRATION HAS TO DEAL WITH.
AND GETTING THIS THROUGH IN THE
MEXICANS AND THE CANADIANS THAT
HELD IN ON A FEW STICKING POINTS
REGARDING DAIRY IS AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT, BUT IT IS A
LITTLE BIT TOO EARLY TO MEASURE,
BECAUSE HE WILL HAVE TOUGHER
NEGOTIATORS IN THAT CANADIANS
AND THE MEXICANS, THAT IS THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS AS WE JUST
SAW, I'M LOOKING TOWARDS
SHERIFF BROWN, HE IS A DEMOCRAT
WHO MAY LIKELY RUN FOR
PRESIDENT, HE HAS THE MOST
INTEGRITY AND REPUTATION AS A
RELATES TO WORKERS RIGHTS AND
TRADE, AND HE WILL FIGURE OUT IF
WE CAN GET TRUE DEMOCRATS TO
PASS IT IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE.
>> NOT JUST DEMOCRATS, IF YOU
REPUBLICANS HAVE PIPED UP, MARCO
RUBIO, TWEETING IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTING THIS DEAL WILL PUT
FLORIDA SEASONAL VEGETABLE
GROWERS OUT OF BUSINESS,
ALLOWING THEM TO DUMP PRODUCE ON
THE U.S. MARKET, GOING FORWARD
AMERICA WILL DEPEND ON MEXICO
FOR THE WINTER VEGETABLES,
UNACCEPTABLE.
A FEW OTHERS WHO HAVE WEIGHED IN
AS WELL.
>> IS ANOTHER.
IF MORE JOBS GO TO MEXICO, WHICH
IS A BIG CONCERN, NOT JUST BY
DEMOCRATS AND THE UNIONS, BUT ON
THE RIGHT AS WELL, WILL THERE BE
MORE OUTSOURCING?
WILL THERE BE PROTECTION FOR
INVESTORS AND PROTECTION IF JOBS
GO TO MEXICO OR OTHER PLACES
OVERSEAS TO NANCY PELOSI'S POINT
AND PROVIDING ENVIRONMENT FOR
WORKERS, THE PRESIDENT HAS A
WIN, BUT ARE WE GOING TO SEE A
WIN IN CONGRESS, I'M NOT SURE,
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT OF
PUSHBACK ON BOTH SIDES TO MARCO
RUBIO'S POINT, AGRICULTURE IS
BEING AFFECTED BY THIS, AND A
POLITICAL WIN FOR THE PRESIDENT
BUT I'M NOT SURE WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
HAVE DEMOCRATS TAKING OVER THE
HOUSE COMING UP IN JANUARY.
>> Bret: A DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT COME JANUARY, IN THE
MEANTIME, DAVID, BIG ISSUES AT
THE G20, THE PRESIDENT CANCELING
THE MEETING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN,
BUT THE BIGGEST MEETING TO COME
TOMORROW NIGHT WITH THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT XI.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ALL EYES WILL
BE ON THAT MEANING FOR SURE,
BRET, I HAVE TO TELL YOU THERE
IS ALLOWED TO NOT JUST AT STAKE,
BUT GOING ON, HE IS NOT AT A
MOMENT WHERE HE CAN BLUFF, IT IS
TIME TO PONY UP, HE CANNOT BACK
AWAY.
THERE IS NO WAY, SO WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN?
ECONOMICALLY WE KNOW THAT
AMERICA IS DOING WELL, THAT IS A
STRONG HAND TO GO INTO ALL OF
THIS WITH BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IF
HE CAN COME AWAY WITH SOMETHING
ON INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT
AND ALL OF THIS FORCED
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE CHINESE ARE DOING, THAT
WILL BE A BIG VICTORY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION BUT HAVING SAID
THAT WE HAVE A LONG ROAD AHEAD
OF US.
THE ONE THAT I WILL POINT OUT IS
THAT OVER 250 BILLION MORE IN
TARIFFS COME JANUARY, AND THAT
IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
DONALD TRUMP CAN RAISE.
>> Bret: I PLAN TO ASK DEFENSE
SECRETARY MADISON ABOUT A NUMBER
OF HOT SPOTS AROUND THE WORLD
INCLUDING CHINA, HERE'S SOME
PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT THE
MEETING YOU HAVE TO COME WITH PE
MEETING YOU HAVE TO COME WITH PI
MEETING YOU HAVE TO COME WITH PT
XI.
>> WE CAN MAKE A DEAL, THAT WILL
BE GOOD, I THINK THAT THEY WANT
TO AND WE WOULD LIKE TO AND WE
WILL SEE.
WE WILL BE MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT XI FOR A WHILE, THE
MOST PART TOMORROW WOULD BE THE
BIG MEETING.
IN THE MEANTIME THE STAFF IS
WORKING, A LOT OF VERY TALENTED
PEOPLE ARE WORKING, LARRY
KUDLOW'S REPRESENTATIVES ARE
DEALING WITH THEM ON A CONSTANT
BASIS.
>> Bret: LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK, ART AT THE DEAL.
>> THAT IS TRUE, I DO NOT EXPECT
A FULL-FLEDGED DEAL TOMORROW,
THE PROBLEM AND THE CHALLENGE
HERE THAT IS DIFFERENT FOR THE
PRESIDENT THEN SAY WHAT HE FACED
IN NORTH KOREA IS THAT WE REALLY
HAVE TWO COMPETING FACTIONS,
CLEARLY THE ECONOMIC AND
BUSINESS INTERESTS, THAT'S WHY
HIS ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TO
GET IT DEAL SOONER THAN LATER,
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
EFFECT ON THE ECONOMY, BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT IT FROM A NATIONAL
SECURITY PERSPECTIVE, THE
CHINESE ARE NOT GOING TO COME
OUT AND ADMIT THAT THEY HAVE
DONE ON IP, THE TAFT, OR HOW
THEY HAVE OPERATED IN SOCIETY,
NOR PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE, HIS
VISION ON HOW CHINA IS GOING TO
LEAD THE WORLD, AND I CANNOT
WAIT TO HEAR YOUR INTERVIEW, BUT
I DO NOT THINK TO BE HYPERBOLIC,
BUT WE ARE AT A MOMENT WHERE WE
ARE IN A GENERATIONAL STRUGGLE
WITH CHINA AND THE PRESIDENT,
ONE OF THE MOST BRILLIANT THINGS
THAT HE HAS DONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FOR HE AND HIS
TEAM TO KEEP THE HEAT ON THE
CHINESE.
AND I HOPE THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
DO IT.
THERE IS NO NEED TO COME OUT OF
THIS WEEKEND WITH SOME MAGIC
DEAL TO SETTLE UP.
>> Bret: QUICKLY A LOT OF THE
LEADERS KNOW HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
OPERATES, THE JAPANESE
PRIME MINISTER CAME WITH NEWS OF
POTENTIALLY TWO NEW FACTORIES OF
AUTOMAKERS TO THE U.S. AND IT
SEEMS PERHAPS THAT THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT WILL COME WITH SOME
DELIVERABLES, BUT IF IT IS NOT
EVEN IN A BIG DEAL.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK BOTH CHINA AND THE
UNITED STATES IS SEEING IS THAT
THE TARIFFS HAD NOT HAD THE
IMPACT OF THAT THEY WANT, I
AGREE, MANY DEMOCRATS AGREE ON
FAIR TRADE PRACTICES BY CHINA,
BUT THE TRADE DEFICIT CONTINUES
TO GROW, AND WE ARE NOT SEEN
FACTORIES PICKED UP AND MOVE OUT
OF CHINA INTO OTHER LOCATIONS IN
ASIA, IN ADDITION TO THAT, WHAT
DO WE WANT LONG TERM?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID IN THE 2016
CAMPAIGN, A PROMISED THAT HE HAS
NOT KEPT WAS THAT HE WAS GOING
TO COME AFTER CHINA BEFORE THEIR
CURRENCY MANIPULATION, THAT WILL
NOT COME UP TOMORROW.
I THINK WHAT WILL HAPPEN AS BOTH
PARTIES ARE GOING TO AGREE, THIS
IS NOT WORKING OUT THE WAY WE
WANTED, WE CAN COME TO A DEAL,